well I think the biggest thing is that
I'm gonna bring him to my coven he's
convinced that I he Jesus is gonna rock
my world
amen Kelsey hi my name is Rachel and I
am a Satanist my name is Matt and I'm a
Christian what I follow was Anton LaVey
Satanism which is modern Satanism Satan
is just a Latin word for opposition we
don't believe in like a deity
it's an overarching theme of unity with
nature and self so I'm a
non-denominational Christian I was
brought up going to church every single
week I worship just by prayer I worship
by living my life and helping people
honestly I'm a little scared I don't go
to a party and be like hello it's me the
Satanist
but that has happened to me a lot with
Christianity where they're like have you
heard the good word a lot of people
around me had reservations about going
and I'm going why not it just gives us
an opportunity to show everybody the
love of Jesus Christ and the power of
the word of God I'm super excited to
meet Rachel hi hello we know each other
we met at Diane's house
well I think the biggest thing is that
I'm gonna bring him to my coven we're
gonna chant together I'm gonna be
terrified well I'm gonna be hungover at
your church so okay I can imagine that
well can be saved well being hungover oh
honey who said I need to be saved how do
you know what do you do with these you
you seem to know I may have been in them
before okay Jesus boy I see you are you
right-handed or left-handed I'm
right-handed I'm left him okay yeah it
works
see see where's the hole let's do it you
ready I'm hungry I'm hungry yeah let's
see let's go sacrifice a pig right I'm
kidding that's a joke I'm hit okay all
right dumplings while resting
they're like Hollywood people
forever buck
yummy
tastes like the body and price of a lot
of good satanic stuff in here what is it
dirty welcome to your for the first
party that's fine preacher I want to see
this son yes
yeah this book one do we have to get
this I was trying to show him some like
godly comic books but turns out comic
book community's not a big fan of God
yeah we like a real thing this is really
good malt scotch whiskey you're fine
you're fine loosen up a little bit
libras God even God drank a lot of
crisis Ryan with that means you better
come in alone
basically I'm here with some cousin
ladies and uh Sam's gonna read not Sarah
this is your current state real a
fortune these are your hopes and fears
it's like all of the like material
wealth and like wisdom and like all the
things Matt how did you feel about your
first reading I don't know if this sway
is my life at all yeah oh look at this
look at that ah oh my gosh yeah this is
really a little it's like a little
cushion maybe a drink well good night
Rachel it's time to go to church oh yeah
really get saved no I guess we moved to
a bed in the middle of the night I've
never slept in the same bed as the
Satanist before I'm a lot of people
stress so there were times last night
that I was I felt a little fear but I
didn't I didn't let that get in my way
good for God has not given us the spirit
of fear and timidity but of power love
and self-discipline hakuna matata hakuna
wow it's time for church is this okay to
wear - yes theirs is about coming as you
are Oh like that Nirvana song sure I'm
feeling a little weird
honestly I don't not looking for excited
I'm excited but I'm happy that Matt is
excited
[Music]
[Music]
how do you feel how do you feel you got
saved Rose her hand up high that was a
non-consensual Prince I was so open my
heart opens did I do okay hey I'm sorry
I can't I couldn't help but laugh really
appreciate being an environment where
people feel a sense of community and
people feel empowered by a thing if they
mean God to feel that way
green I just don't happen to need God to
feel that way I feel that way every day
when I wake up and I see myself in the
mirror and I go oh hell yes yes clean
well you certainly felt it in there
definitely felt something in there well
we're gonna go get food yeah post-church
fuel up there we go traditional
Mediterranean meal to appease Jesus well
my son bees are a little different from
this and I usually wake up late and then
I go to brunch there's no rest for the
wicked guess not
you know me so well I'm good and I'm bad
duality of man as above so below you
can't knock me from you more than I like
you in this moment good could be hard no
please no I love you I love you too Hey
I was actually really surprised at how
genuinely nervous I was and I really
didn't know what to expect I thought
that I was gonna feel like a lamb to
slaughter and I kind of did but it
wasn't terrible it was it was so much
better than what I expected it really
was the most important thing to take
from this experience about Satanism in
general is that it's not what you think
it is it's all about humanity and
finding love and finding God within your
the other the people on earth and what
you can share tangibly I think that in
the world that we live in today
Trump's America or the Muslim ban and
and things like that I just I just think
that if I Christian can be handcuffed to
a Satanist for an entire weekend I think
our entire country can do the same and
bridge any gap one thing that I think
both Christians at least the church that
we were at today and Satanists have in
common is that we need to unify as
people I'm going to miss Rachel so much
I am NOT going to miss this I love you
and Jesus loves you amen
Hey amen you wanted on cups so bad again
oh my god do you ever mark [ __ ] no dude
[Music]